yeah what i mean i'm i don't normally
ask questions uh about me but what do
you i don't even i mean i was 14 i don't
remem what i remember is of course like
how cool it was that like you
and we called i mean obviously mark paul
being zack for those who don't know mark
paul gosselin zach from save by the bell
and then sean patrick flannery we called
powder because he was actually he did a
movie called powder
right
and so and like my sister and i and
there's like i can remember this picture
uh that we had all together hanging out
around the go-kart but i just remember
thinking how cool it was i was like wow
these people are into racing but the
question i have just because you were
there back then
i don't even what was i like i don't
know well
what i remember most was you kind of you
you were shy-ish
right in the beginning like you were you
were i guess you were probably a little
with with them mostly but probably a
little star struck and kind of like oh
my god they're here that's kind of weird
it was but it was always that right it
was always a bit of the you know
why are they here right like yeah that's
a very much the question why are you
here what are you doing
world crossing that doesn't make sense
to people right
um
but you but but like because we were all
together in that tent we we would go out
and watch all the other races and i
remember watching you in one of the
races and going
oh she can drive
like she's got that fire and i think
when you would come back in we were you
know we were like dude girl that was
awesome and you were kind of like yeah
whatever and it was like you had like it
wasn't it wasn't a good race but we were
impressed by it okay and
but that but that's where you like for
me
you gain the respect because it no
longer mattered that we were who we were
you were like i didn't have the race
that i wanted
it didn't matter who else was around
right right it wasn't like i was like
thanks that's really i was like whatever
yeah you were like
the race didn't didn't go
exactly as we planned it you watch i'm
like i probably was like did you watch
the race did you see what i'd i yeah of
course
right and it was like but to us it was
like
you know especially because
if i remember correctly there were
literally only like three or four girls
that maybe were there right there was a
girl from canada that raised julianna
juliana um there was you
um and like every once in a while
you'd see another person come in and now
that'd be about it but but really
unfortunately they would most likely
always be kind of at the back and so but
you were the you were you two were the
ones that were like in there competing
like
like okay yeah
you get next to each other it was good i
mean i was better but she was good she
was good she was good and and like what
was interesting was her and i
had many run-ins
really oh a ton
oh my god i have a story too about a run
with her what was your run-in well we we
ended up we were in the same class
so
we ended up like
we were in
barry ontario
she was canadian she was canadian so it
was her kind of home race she was a big
part of helping get scusa there
and so
you know she was expected to win
yeah and she was they were part i think
her
family was imported the burrell carts
right right right so they were it was a
big factory
right for them to to to do something
and we went into one of the heats
and
she bumped me out of the way
okay
i mean if we can now draw in the
beginning of this conversation about
fighting in school it's like if you want
to fight me i just you don't know how
this goes i mean this
you bump me out of the way
i mean
a couple corners later
that's quick she got bumped out of the
way
and we we get in after the heat she ends
up finishing near the back she and she
and like she storms down
right and up in my face gives me the
shove and i was like
like i can't do anything here you're
like i'm still
i'm a grown-up
yeah i just used to hear that back in
the day about me they're like you can't
start a fight because i can't fight you
back i can't like i can't but like
different when you're an adult like it's
still male female uncool can't do it
but i was also an adult yeah as a kid
like
what
how does this yell at a 13 year old how
does this end right and she i think she
was a little she was probably like 17.
yeah she was probably in the seniors
class so she was at least
right but i was like i can't i can't we
can't but i okay
right and
i was like
beat it
in the next race whatever but you know
but she but she was a fighter she was a
hardcore
go after it get it done you know trying
to win every race um had that you know
canadian
uh you know uh uh
french canadian fire and and you know
but but what i remember most about you
was that you ultimately was a hardcore
go get it take no bull
um racer and it was like immediate
respect and
and i've always said and that laughingly
i was like well you know
danica used to race for me
you should tell that story i need to
know that sir i didn't know that story i
was like
yeah at the supernational she came and
she was under our tent and we had the
whole because we were we were basically
funding tony card so like we were that
week basically funding the entire
operation and that was the year that
jean decided to do a i mean we had the
biggest tent by a long shot i mean there
were 30 carts under the tent so
you know after that i think we ended up
i feel like i remember like my dad
thought there's too many people in there
so we got our we like moved out of the
tent and like got our own space because
it was just like too much and not enough
attention and
and so yeah we we moved out but my
julianna story is fairly similar i think
i was racing somewhere in maybe indiana
or something and
she bumped me and then the race finished
and i didn't get back to her so
afterwards i i was close enough and
after the checkered flag i just came up
behind her and slammed her so hard and
sent her off
and
you know it's really you know it
shouldn't matter
i'm gonna say it shouldn't matter but um
after the checkered flag they don't
usually they don't like you to um do
those kinds of things so okay
yeah it's always the second offender do
you really always notice that
you look at all of sports you look at
sports you look at racing i can think of
all kinds of times with myself and my
sport but you look at it and the
antagonizer
doesn't get in trouble absolutely it's
the retaliation that gets in trouble and
that's just not fair well i you know i
i've just i've just said i'm just gonna
accept it i'm not gonna stop doing it
like i was like yeah the second the
second person gets in more trouble
okay oh well okay but it's going to
happen
right and you know i mean obviously as
you as you continue to do amazing um
like
there is a there's a very difficult
reality that's very different in racing
than it is in many aspects of the world
um where i believe like
you had to hit her
i know what you mean right like you like
that moment the next time you two come
together on a racetrack
like she's gotta think just for a split
second
can i do this
because i know what the end result is
going to be is coming back
unless it was clean unless it was fair
it's coming back
yeah i remember this this this it
honestly felt like a burden because it's
not my nature like i don't love being
overly aggressive and taking people out
and it's not my nature i like to be fair
and i remember in nascar especially with
bumpers that when people would do stuff
to me there was this really big pressure
around me where
it was like you better do something
about that you better go take them out
you better and it was like ah and you
know for anybody who watched me
i didn't always execute very well
i sometimes took myself out
and then like one of the times where i
got hit by a driver and then i came back
out it was at martinsville and i hit
him back and tried to take him out but i
took myself out right and um i
that was the race
that matt kenzeth and joey logano had it
out and matt kenseth came back on the
track after he had been taken out and
and crashed joey logano and he was in
the running for the championship and um
it was because
logano did it to him the race before at
michigan and so because nascar was under
such high scrutiny scrutiny for what
what kenzeth did um i'm sort of
blanketing myself in this is that i got
a huge point like i think i got fined
like 70 000
and got like six months probation for it
i mean like i had a huge fine for it all
because it was kind of under this really
highly scrutinized race about since i
was not it was not for position with him
just like matt and joey weren't for
position all of a sudden it turned into
this big thing but yeah it's just not
fair in general but it's the way it goes
and i think i mean
you know that's probably a good attitude
just you have to you're right in racing
you do kind of have to stand up for
yourself so there's a second thought but
i think that
i don't think it's just racing i think
in life if somebody
does you wrong
and you have to sort of correct it there
might be some sort of repercussion of
that but that person better think twice
before they screw you over again